now during the game because it's a five
minute game i go relatively fast
you know i involve you i ask people
questions but i go fast and not
everything is going to be easy to follow
if you have questions i try to answer
each and every question i want every
single one of you
to feel like you are learning and to
understand every step of my thinking
process it's a very ambitious goal
but it's one that i try my best to
adhere to
[Music]
and without further ado let us get
started it's a five minute game
let's go you guys ready to learn we're
playing an 800 that's our highest rated
opponent so far
we're going to stick to the main
openings we've been playing which is e5
and e4
he goes for the scotch game now in the
scotch
we have so far been playing the bishop
out to c5 development with tempo
very important he takes on c6 now queen
f6 is charlie's move against xqc but
let's um
let's just take the knight here and i
got my own notebook where i write down
exactly what i will emphasize after the
game
so what do we do what do we do in this
position we need to keep developing
in order to keep developing we need to
get this bishop out so let's go d6
let's go d6 to open up the diagonal why
does the pawn structure not matter
i will explain later why even though
black's pawn structure may seem damaged
that's actually a good thing
as well how do we continue developing
buck pull in thank you
how do we continue developing
who and nothing to invent here no need
to reinvent the wheel let's just develop
actively good job malcolm tucker
okay now and this is where we get
to the art of violating rules
strategically okay goes bishop g5
now i don't like this bishop let's get
it out of here and
okay well that was a mistake bishop he
should have gone bishop f4 what did we
take with obviously the queen
fantastic we've gotten rid of his bishop
and we're threatening checkmate our
queen is very nicely placed
on an active square all our pieces are
playing depending on what he does
if he castles or if he goes queen d2 i
assume he's going to defend against mate
well there's one more thing that we need
to do before we even need to think about
plans what is that one thing
what is that one thing that we need to
do we need to castle
okay let's take care of the fundamentals
before we
um before we think about anything now
what
oh well okay b3 we know from our
previous speedrun experience that
whenever our opponent pushes a pawn
we need to understand what has been left
behind what weakness has been left
behind in this case it's very easy to
see
that he has blundered a knight in trying
to defend his b2 pawn preemptively
retroactively you guys might realize
that i wanted to put my rook on ba to
try to induce that movement he's done
that for us
let's recap really quickly how we're
going to win this game there are two
main methodologies toward winning and
converting material advantage
one is to trade off all the pieces and
to reach an endgame and the other is to
use that extra piece and attack
we can do a little bit of both how can
we do a little bit of both we have a
move that offers a trade
and if he goes for that trade we
simultaneously enhance our attacking
possibilities
toward his king when i say attacking
possibilities you should be thinking of
this f2 pawn
and you should be thinking of how to
increase the pressure on that pawn
one is queen d4 perfectly good move but
i personally
like the move bishop e6 because i keep
the queen on this beautiful c3 square
where it's unassailable
he cannot play rookie three
[Laughter]
sorry that was an evil left he did play
rookie three but
just gives up the rook and he resigns
there's a popcorn stuck in my mouth
sorry oh god
well that was a quick one okay and um
a couple things a lot of people take on
d4 we have been
over that and the reason that this is
not a good move for black could does
somebody
remember so i'm gonna play devil's
advocate for a second i'm gonna play
devil's advocate
isn't it the case that you don't want to
develop your queen in the opening and so
this would be good for black like why is
this not
good for black even though the queen is
out in the opening yeah you lose the
tempo but
the other thing that i want people to
understand here is that
you don't have a knight on b8 to attack
the queen with if you compare this to
the scandi
if you compare this to the scandi here
white has the move knight c3 with tempo
develop him with tempo
here he cannot develop a tempo and so
the queen is actually nicely centralized
so we play bishop c5 and here if you
guys remember the game
famous game xqc against charlie it was
this position
in which xqc would move moves uh
overturned
the opposite move or played c3 so queen
f6 is actually another move
but we took with a b pawn now why are we
not taking with the d
pawn and opening up the center well the
reason is simple he takes our queen we
don't want to get
our king out to d8 so early we need a
castle i don't want an end game this
early
now daniel why are you excuse me
guys sorry guys i've been talking a lot
today
i'm gonna try to hydrate as much as
possible
now daniel you might be saying why are
you ruining your fun structure
as i've said before pawn structure
should not be the most important
consideration
unless that pawn structure is near the
king what do we gain
in return for seemingly ruining our pawn
structure
okay why what are we gaining and there's
two things i'm looking for
first of all trjn says open b file
exactly
later on we could put our rook on the b
file and what is the second thing this
might be a little bit less obvious
november swimming
that man deserves a sub because he just
wanted out the other thing
now this pawn break is going to be a lot
easier to execute because that b
pawn that c pawn newly created is going
to be able to support that pawn push so
you guys see how there's many sides to
the same coin
okay we go d6 uh part of the reason that
we did not go knight f6
immediately this would be a little bit
inaccurate because it would give white
an extra opportunity
in the scotch particularly you always
have to be careful about allowing this
move there's e5
this is not the end of the worlds but
why allow that when we can simply first
play d6
okay knight f6 bishop g5 h6 he takes on
f6 which is a typical mistake at this
level
you see a capture you make the capture
you gotta critically evaluate every
trade that you make the move bishop
h4 would be a lot more effective because
it keeps the pin jason 77 asks why d6
and 95 well
remember to count defenders and
attackers there's one two three
attackers
one two defenders there's more attackers
than defenders
so this would blunder a pun sad thing i
would have otherwise
loved to play this move okay so bishop
h4 would have kept the pin
now i want you guys to answer me or
attempt to answer the following question
would we play the move g5 here is there
a case to be made for playing this move
if so what is the case if not why not bc
says do not push the pawn
no most people are saying no why am and
i
haven't am i not getting rid of the pin
isn't that a good thing it weakens your
king's side bingo
it weakens the king's side too much no
problem he might without castle queen
side big deal
big whoop i'm gonna castle queenside
well guess what
we did ruin our pawn structure a little
bit so castling queen side would be
unthinkable here with so many open
squares
so you got to be very careful about
making a move such as g5 sometimes you
want to play it
but in this position i would delay that
move i would probably
even consider castling and
yes this pin is unpleasant that is true
but you can get rid of the pin by moving
the queen out of the way you don't have
to go g5
and once your pieces are more in the
game then you could actually still
consider going g5 in some circumstances
but that's a move you got to be very
very careful about
okay so that's basically it i mean he
took an f6 and very quickly blundered
if he played a move such as queen d2 i
was considering going rook b8
this would be emphasizing the benefit
of um you know of opening the b file if
he goes b3
once again this would be a blunder it
doesn't blunder the knight directly but
what does this now
allow bike record thank you for the sub
appreciated bishop b4 is correct and now
the knight is lost
so how should white actually defend if
you were playing white here let's flip
the board
how would you actually want to defend
the pawn this is very important
how do you defend the pawn without
making an incredibly passive move such
as rook b1
but but guys problem with rook v1 is
that the rook is now
completely sort of enslav i mean it's
it's just it's not doing anything other
than defending the pawn you got to be
very very careful
about a heavy piece that could be doing
a lot of heavy lifting
doing something as trivial as just
defending a pawn so the move bishop b3
very nice guys would be much better
because now you are organically
defending the pawn
and the bishop is multitasking unlike in
life
sometimes it's good for pieces to
multitask the bishop is simultaneously
pressuring this diagonal and
it's throwing its body against the rook
and it's very nicely supported by pawns
thank you slipped the jab for 500
i you're all good man i appreciate the
support thank you so much for that kind
message
that's exactly right and once he played
b3
a lot of people were suggesting queen d4
here that's a fine move
totally fine move but i would argue that
after queenie2
that queen on d4 becomes very
susceptible to the move rook d1
while the queen on c3 if you think about
it is not susceptible to rookie 3 which
he played anyway
what is the purpose of the move bishop
e6 what do we gain from this trade well
we gave it
the trade of minor pieces which is good
and we also gain
huge pressure on the f2 square which we
could then transmute
into some sort of a tactic so here
actually already and this is a bit
advanced
black has a tactic that allows him not
only to win the spawn but to enhance
the attack it's a two move sequence
could somebody find it
and i'll get to what if white doesn't
trade in a moment
is correct rook takes after rook f2r
cafe and well guess what
white doesn't have any pieces to defend
the stroke with obviously if he defends
the queen that does not help i mean
you're defending the stroke and you're
attacking this one
so if he actually takes you don't need
to take the queen this is just check me
um somebody was asking a very pertinent
question
what if the bishop moves away what have
we gained by
well what have we gained we've developed
our bishop now we can bring a rook into
the game and later or even immediately
we can still open up the f file by
playing f5
okay so just wanted to be clear that
these are the two methods of
of converting a material advantage and
we can do both
okay so last thing before we move on to
the next game some somebody asked
um knight to d1 you are making the same
mistake the knight is now
only defending the pawn and doing
nothing else
it's actually sowing disunity among
white's ranks
no pun intended because it's
disconnecting the rooks and you really
don't want to do that it's also
relinquishing the defense of the e4 pawn
which black can
pick up on by playing rook e8 okay um
so last thing somebody asked what does
compensation mean what the hell does
this word mean compensation
you hear a throat okay sacrifice all
night okay compensation okay
but okay i sacrificed his opponent i had
compensation
what does compensation mean now
obviously in life to compensate someone
for a service rendered
means to you know somebody renders a
service and you get compensated let's
say with money
and the kernel of that is contained in a
chess sense as well
compensation is when you sacrifice
material let's say sack of pawn
and you get something in return for the
pawn
and that something is very broad it
could be a million different things it
could be an attack
but but it doesn't have to be an attack
it could be something as simple as an
outpost it could be something as simple
as
an open file it could be something as
simple as a single piece or a
desirable trade uh you have to think of
compensation in a very broad sense
to understand its full meaning and the
more obscure the compensation the more
positional
the compensation the harder it is to
decide upon
to decide upon a particular sacrifice
now let me give you guys a very quick
example of
what i don't want to spend too long on
this but let's talk about what
compensation may look like
one second please let's talk about what
or it could be a square i will show you
guys a very famous example
of sacrificing something for
compensation
okay um let me think about the game
um okay one second please
i will show you guys a game between uh
from the
famous tigran petrossian who was of
course a former world champion known for
his positional mastery
and he had a very famous game in 1953
this
some of you will be familiar with this
particular moment but i think it's a
great illustration of the notion of
compensation
and what it exactly entails uh before we
move on to the next game
um all right so i and again these
concepts like outposts all this stuff i
will define it properly as we go along
i'm gonna try to
weave it into uh our natural discussion
if that if that i don't know if that
makes sense but
uh that's what i'm going to try to do
now
one second guys i'm not sure why this
isn't working there we go
so the position in front of you was uh
played between samuel roshefsky one of
the strongest american players of the
20th century and tigran petrossian was
black
zurich 1953 black is worse
okay because look at white's beautiful
pawn center
d4 e5 you know if black allows d5 i'm
not going to take too long evaluating
this
but in this position petrosian played an
exchange sacrifice
in order to to stop the motion
of white's central pawns petrossian
plays rookie six
he sacrifices the exchange which means
rook for bishop or knight
rushevsky doesn't take it immediately
but let's imagine that roshewski would
have taken the knight what is it that
black gets in return for this exchange
as aladdin 64 is pointing out
black gets an amazing square for his
knight
what is this square and how does black
get this knight to that square
he gets a center pawn in which contests
white central pawn motion that is true
but look at this amazing
juicy square for the night and look at
what happens when black brings this
knight here
it's actually the best move actually it
is the best move according to the
computer
this knight is unassailable they call it
an eternal night in russian
it stops the center it's amazing in its
control its domination over the board
is white still a little bit better yes
white is still a little bit better but
this is the essence of positional
compensation
you get something very weighty in return
for an exchange or a piece
it's not actually mysterious this is
what's known as a positional sacrifice
when people hear this word oh my god oh
positional sacrifice
i don't i don't want to even talk about
it but that is what a positional
sacrifice really is
all it really is is a sacrifice in
return for something positional such as
a good square
okay um that's what it is
how do you come up with this move well
petrosian realized that if he allows a
move such as e6
then he's going to be run out of the gym
and so he tells himself i have to stop
this at all costs
and it's worth sacrificing something to
stop this idea there are
far more mind-blowing positional
sacrifices which i will get to later i
will write this down
positional sex but for now i just wanted
to define that i hope that makes it a
little bit clear i'm sorry i went so
quickly through this position coin
eternal russian and russian eternal
knight in russian is virtually coined
of course my pleasure let's continue
guys everybody ready for a second speed
run game
i'm again backwards pawn outpost you
guys can google that
but i will eventually define all these
concepts in the course of our games but
i want to keep things
moving dynamically so let's get let's
continue
okay so we're going to go e4 we're
playing net camps already
up to the 800s and that already stumps
them apparently
let's see what he does okay he might not
make a move now again all ratings are
refunded
i will abort in 15 okay he goes d6 so he
goes for what's called
the perk opening he allows white to gain
control of the center
this is not a bad opening if black plays
well but at the level of
my opponent most people who play this
move are not fully aware
of how to play this and they get in
trouble very quickly i'm gonna try to
show you
okay so this is of the category of
openings that people play to try to
intimidate you
to throw you out of your comfort zone
you guys remember that when we see an
opening like this we need to abide very
strictly by opening principles if we do
that
we're not going to get in a lot of
trouble there's a couple of ways to play
this
we can control the center even more with
our pawns or we can begin developing our
pieces
either strategy is good normally in such
situations we have prioritized
development
but since we're rated a little bit
higher let me show you how i would
actually play so i would actually play
the move c4
expanding our central control but
because our center is so vast
okay and this is where people run into a
lot of trouble so listen carefully
people get too fixated on on expanding
the center
and forget that they need to support it
with their pieces so i would not play f4
which would not be a bad move
but that would overexpand my center it's
more important to start developing
than to keep expanding and expanding and
expanding so let's get our night out
and start enhancing our control over the
center he's developing terribly i mean
you guys can see
he's just playing so passively and
f4 is good here but again i would
probably play f4
but let's practice sound
positional principles so let's continue
developing
okay he his clock wasn't running for
some reason he's played bishop e7 and i
really lagged whoa
okay so something froze there okay let's
continue sorry
i don't know what was going on anyways i
lost a bunch of time there was some
server lag
bishop d3 we're gonna keep developing
now notice what i want you guys to
notice what i want you guys to notice
is that is that he's developing very
powerfully we're continuing to develop
where people really struggle is in
transforming
in transforming their space advantage
into something more tangible so if you
are among those people i want you to
look carefully
and we have not a lot of time here on
the clock so i'm going to play a little
bit faster
but i want to look carefully at how i
actually do that
everything is nicely developed other
than this bishop
but what do we do with that how do we
actually
make stuff happen out of that well
normally when i say
make stuff happen what i really mean is
we need to expand in the center
and we need to start attacking on one of
the flanks which of the flanks do you
think we're going to start attacking on
why did we put this bishop on d3
why do we put this bishop on d3 how
might we
open that bishop up and what kind of
stuff are we going to be looking for
when we do that bingo we're going to be
looking to play e5
and when we play e5 those of you
familiar with the
greek gift sacrifice there's one thing
to bear in mind which is incredibly
important
which is that when you are doing the
greek gift sacrifice and after the game
before i leave
i'm going to talk about let me take
first just to avoid the central tension
and then i'll play e5
the greek gift sacrifice starts with
bishop takes h7 followed by knight g5
here black has a bishop on e7 guys so
one of the preconditions
for the greek gift is that the g5 square
has to be uncovered by
your opponent here it is covered so we
can't do the great gift
but we can do something else and what i
want you guys to understand is that
even though you might be thinking of
attacking you should
always be looking for more simple ways
to win such as just winning your
opponent's material
so here mike is seeing the move i look
at this night i see whoa
whoa whoa whoa where is this knight it's
on the rim
does this knight have any escape squares
no it doesn't knight f6 ef
knight f4 bishop f4 so we can just trap
the knife by playing g4 i'm violating a
rule here
daniel aren't you pushing a pawn in
front of your king you just said this
was bad
this is an exception to the rule because
i'm winning a darn knight
if he had more pieces on the king side
okay maybe i would have done this with a
lot of reservations
but he doesn't have anything on the
king's side this is the consequences of
him developing his pieces terribly
the consequences of that is that he is
not able
to exploit the fact that i pushed upon
in front of my king he has to give up
his knight
let's continue attacking how do we
continue well in order to attack this
pawn
we need to bring some pieces into the
game in particular i'm looking at this
knight on c3 where can we put this
knight
yeah g5 is good g5 is good let's go g5
let's actually push the bishop away and
if he takes on c3 that plays into our
hands
that actually is a trade which is good
for us and
we get rid of one of the defenders
surrounding his king
which is also good okay well let's take
the bishop thank you for giving it to us
and now
very important not to play queen h5 that
would be a very tempting move and it
would be a very bad one because he plays
g6
so let's get 94 in just centralizing the
knight
now we're going to get the queen to h5
and we are going to accumulate the
pieces around our opponent's kit
um he actually probably should take on
e4 and go g6 but
you know he's on his last legs here uh
and the question is
is he going to defend as tenaciously as
possible or
um well or is he going to succumb
quickly what are we threatening in this
position i have a feeling that he might
miss this
i have a feeling that he might play
moves to just e5 if i know these players
what are we threatening very good guys
knight f6
how do you find a move like this it's
simple you see h7 you know that you're
trying to attack that square
what's stopping this from being
checkmate obviously it's the fact that
we have a knight here
obstructing the bishop so knight f6 now
i see that it's not entirely made he can
still take with the knight
if he takes with a knight he defends h7
we take the knight
he's got to go g6 and what kind of mate
am i already thinking about
what kind of mate am i already thinking
about after he goes g6
i want the name of this mate bingo
lobster instrument can i make can i made
him immediately with queen h6
don't rush guys very important to be
disciplined
can i play queen h6 no you cannot
because of queen takes f6
that's okay i saw that so what we're
going to do is we're going to drop the
queen back
then we're going to bring the bishop out
and now we're threatening the lobster
pincermate
he has to go h5 in order to defend he
doesn't so let's
lobster rip into him you see how clear
when you're up a piece and you're
attacking like this you're not always in
a hurry thank you flyerton good to see
you my friend
good to see you my friend
and this will be the last game of the
stream guys and i will return around
1am or so for another hour
to continue the speed run bishop takes
f6 and we can actually pre-move queen g7
because
because there is just no defense now
very quickly what if he had played h5
in order to block the queen's at brock
block the queen's access to h6 well
here's how i think of this position do
you guys see the relationship between
the bishop and the queen
okay this relationship is a very
important one i have told you guys about
it before when there is a relationship
like this called an x-ray
a piece staring at the queen in
particular through the lens of another
piece
you immediately and everybody's seeing
this so quickly that's incredible
you immediately need to start thinking
okay if i play f7 that's going to be a
check i'm going to win a queen
and so you can play bishop takes g6
sacrificing one bishop
f takes g6 f7 and you win the queen
but daniel you didn't give lobster pinch
remain i thought you wanted to give
lobster pincer mate well that's where
the notion of flexibility comes in
okay you have to be flexible as to the
objective of your attack winning a queen
i think nobody would disagree with me is
a pretty good result of an attack
so that's why it's so important to be
open-minded
to what it is you're trying to
accomplish okay
so that's what i would do if he doesn't
take the bishop then
the road is clear you can play queen
takes h5 or bishop h5
the king is wide open and at your
leisure you could basically give the
lobster pins or mate
all right shinigami thank you so much
for the seven months amazing stuff going
on
and that's basically what i did now
let's quickly go over the game i do have
to run
uh but let's quickly go over the game i
thought i had a little bit more time but
that's okay i might be back guys
um i think that everything i did in the
opening should make sense to you guys i
played bishop d3 because i'm
anticipating him castling
and i want to play e5 and open up the
bishop's control of the h7 square thank
you hortback so much appreciate it
um and here i played e5 and what would i
have done had he played 98 which is a
better move
how do we actually proceed uh with the
attack now one thing that i want to make
very clear
is that when we have a pawn on h7 like
this when we try to greek gift as i said
we can't do this because g5 is under
black's control that is the litmus test
for determining
when a greek gift sacrifice works
sometimes it works even when there is a
piece defending the square that is a
complicated scenario
which i will go to go through later but
i want to talk about the notion of a
battery batteries are when two pieces
are stacked either on top of each other
or on the same diagonal
usually the most effective batteries are
going to be doubled rooks which is a
type of battery
or the most famous battery a queen and a
bishop on the same diagonal
do we want it to be like this no we
don't because when we have a queen
bishop batter
we normally want to lead with the queen
why do we want to lead with the queen
because white threatens checkmate and if
we juxtapose that with this position
this is a serious threat but it's not a
threat of checkmate
there are exceptions to the rules
sometimes the situation is chaotic
so you want your queen behind a wall of
defenders here his pieces are so passive
that we can set up the battery with
total impunity
now wait a second we set up the battery
big whoop he just defends
but the point of the battery isn't to
deliver checkmate right we think he's
going to defend against checkmate
but when he plays g6 he introduces more
weaknesses on the king side this is how
you attack
which we can then exploit by putting our
pieces on better squares
now we can do a bunch of different
things we can get the knight over to f6
and again this position smells of a
lobster pins are made
so what i want to make very clear is
that attacking is not about finding
one idea and then getting super
disappointed when this idea doesn't work
it's about orchestrating ideas and when
these ideas don't work in the sense of
delivering mate we think okay well how
is this idea weakened his position how
do we develop new ideas
that stack on top of what it is that we
were trying to do in the first place
riemann asks a great question
what about bishop c6 to stop queen e4
well there's a couple of things we could
do here we could go rook d1
to create the pin against the screen we
could attack on multiple angles
and guess what if he plays queen b6 we
can already think about playing knight
g5 because we ask ourselves
what is the drawback of his queen move
well
gets the screen away from its control of
g5 so we can play knight g5 to open up
the queen's access to h5
this is all part of the art of attacking
chess attacking is incredibly difficult
that is a skill
we master over the course of many years
um
and um obviously even i have not
mastered attacking
uh it's it's it's something that
involves so many complex elements
that um that there's so many components
moving parts
what are other ways besides a great gift
to translate central control into a
tangible advantage well
jeff i'm talking about them here you're
not seeing greek gift sacrifice what
you're seeing is a sustained effort to
attack the spawn without a greek gift
there's also concepts of transforming a
central advantage into an attack on the
other flank you don't have to
always attack the king but that is the
fundamental
transformation i mean i'll talk also
about queen side attacks
and last question so what if in this
position
what if he just goes h6 well guess what
h6 weakens his king
and how do we exploit this weakness i'm
already thinking of sacrificing that
bishop on h6
later on this is called a hook i'll talk
about hooks later
and i'll talk about other attacking
elements the time being guys i do have
to take off